heard a really great story that Rebecca
dared you to ride the Metro into London
is can you share what exactly happened
no she didn't dare me I was like come on
let's go oh it was you daring her no I
said let's just go we're gonna go right
now right I was like come on let's go
was it were you guys like filming and it
was like no we were working uh I think
it was on Rogue Nation we were working
and there was bad traffic so I was like
let's just go to the metro and just go
in I just put my hat on you know my
headphones and right no one's there and
no one picked you out it was wonderful
you know people on the on the Metro
they're all reading their stuff and they
want to be in their own world so I just
get on and we're there like this and I
remember I was I stood up at the pole
and there was a young girl had her head
set on it must have been about 16 and
she she's just looking at me
like this and then she just goes and she
just looks at everyone on the train like
that and then she just goes back and she
looks at me like this and I just went
she went
all right you know